[Music]
the first official installment of guru
corner guru quarter and we still have to
have a meeting of the minds and get
together and map out this course there's
a lot of demand out there and I know
I've been difficult to pin down and
attractive to maybe we can like you know
start working on an outline and piece
that together because I think people
would really enjoy it and there's
certainly a lot of people who would like
to hear from us well when I listened to
you and and Srimati your wife speaking
and the very the differences in your
approach to work right and you talked
about how you liked to do you know one
thing but you also like to have it
planned out in chunks I thought wow
that's so good for what I want to
achieve also because you know I'll have
to learn that from you in because when
you have your engine pointing all of its
explosive energy in one direction the
car moves forward mm-hmm and when you
have the engine you know you know with
the old style car right there that
valves and all not a lot for not not all
your energy is going forward yeah it's
difficult as life continues to expand to
figure out where to apportion that focus
and that energy and you know I'm in a
fortunate position as I'm sure as I know
you are yourself of having a lot of cool
opportunities and things that you could
do and trying to find like I need to do
I do one thing at a time right so it's
like okay well today I'm doing this so
where as Julie sort of working on a lot
of things at the same time and this is
not how I functions so it's about like
carving out the mental space to just say
okay today I'm focusing on how we're
gonna map this thing out and what will
do that and there's another thing that I
learned at that at that lecture I was
really glad I went I appreciate you guys
coming and and that was that you're your
professional background I didn't know
that you had that behind you as oh as a
lawyer you mean yeah oh yeah it was a
lawyer for almost 20 years yeah well I
mean it was it was a classic example of
being stuck in the wrong profession for
a very long period of time thinking
originally like well this is what I'm
supposed to do and you know I have a of
come to understand a very high pain
threshold which I you know put to good
use in the athletic endeavors that I
also probably put it to good use in
those 20 years yeah but I think I think
I'm thinking I'm suffering in this
career but I'm just thinking well this
is what men of my situation are supposed
to do presuming that everyone else is
experiencing the same level of suffering
that I am and just thinking well suck it
up right and and progressively you know
dying on the inside until I came so
overwhelming and like I can go out and
do all these crazy Iron Man's and and
suffer and be in pain but the pain that
I experienced as a result of being in
that career a career that was at odds
with I think the person that I truly am
created much more suffering than
anything I've experienced automatic
pursuits you know the Buddha talked
about the levels of pain there's
physical pain emotional pain
psychological pain and existential pain
and what you were talking about is in
the Ironman is a lot of physical
exertion a lot of physical pain but the
Buddha was talking about how it's the
existential pain which is the most
severe mm-hmm and then next to that is
the psychological pain then next to that
is the emotional pain and so as you go
into what appears to be the more
identifiable pain the ability to
withstand it becomes greater and as a
matter of fact in a career that is not
taking you where you want to go that's
very psycho-emotional right and very
psychological and emotional
it's like crazy-making and the kids
today that are experiencing that because
of the their you know school doesn't
tell them what they're gonna be it
doesn't tell them what they're gonna do
it just sort of feeds them with things
that they obviously need to know some of
which they need to know right and then
they are lost as to you know where is
this pain coming from and a lot of times
that's why they exert pain on themselves
in some of the extreme ways in which
that happens yeah well we saw a pretty
demonstrable example of that this past
week yeah well yeah another I think the
last time we sat down we discussed
school shootings and here we are again
in the wake of you know another
cataclysmic event yeah and you know the
the bad statistic that I just heard was
that since the first of the year they've
been over 30 mass shootings a lot of
which we never heard about mm-hmm yeah
and and we don't hear about the daily
gun violence that is you know taking
people's lives one by one or two by two
and here we are again in the wake of it
with the sort of onslaught of thoughts
and prayers and very little political
will to do anything about it but I think
the the the biggest difference with this
occasion is seeing the kids in front of
television cameras speaking up for the
very first time and really taking charge
and taking control of the narrative in a
way that we haven't seen before and
that's uplifting and encouraging but
also it's it's uh it's heart-wrenching
because they shouldn't have to be the
ones who are leading the charge in
creating this change that we need when
you were talking about your earlier
career withholding you from that which
you felt was your destiny or your
passion you think about the careers of
politicians their passion is to be
reelected their side job is to govern
there's nothing more passionate than a
politician on the stump
campaigning on the phone asking for
contribution that's where their passion
is employed when they go to governing
they have to honor those who have
donated in that passion and that's
common to you know to all of the
politicians the only one that is
passionate about life in this instance
are the kids whose lives are being taken
and so I am in full support of radical
and disruptive solutions and that's what
it's going to take because what we have
here is the collision of a lot of
different marketplaces we have the
marketplace of arms and weapons we've
got the marketplace of politicians we've
got the marketplace of those who are in
charge of politicians their largest
donors and then we've got the
marketplace of our children trying to
grow up in this world and it's the
collision of these marketplaces that is
so gut-wrenching because you see the
inequity and the and the lack of balance
and so I've got some really strong ideas
on solution ever since you said you know
that you thought it would be really good
to cover topicals topical events you
know I'm thinking that this is a good
platform for us to actually discuss and
chew up the ideas not every idea is
going to be great but every idea is
going to stimulate well let's get into
those ideas I mean the the minoo it's
top of mind for somebody who lives in
the practical world our subjects like
you know gun control reform
legislatively in terms of access to guns
and also campaign finance reform so that
entities like the NRA don't hold so much
sway over our
our leaders but I'm interested in the
more ethereal spiritual solutions that
you're probably contemplating and
they're not just pray harder the kids
really debunk that one when they said
prayers don't stop bullets
so the the first thing that comes to
mind is I did a comparative within my
own within my own thoughts what did it
take to create the TSA we all remember
not everyone on on this podcast but you
and I both remember airports before the
TSA and we know that they have put
billions and billions of dollars into
airport security and yet the number of
people a year that died from airplane
crashes or from terrorists attacks on
airplanes that caused airplanes to crash
is miniscule in comparison to the number
of people that died from gun deaths but
there was something that created a
passion and a reason to produce the TSA
and the TSA in its what since 2001 so
we've got seventeen years of evolution
have gone through many different stages
of technology and so my first attitude
is that we've got these polarized
attitudes between those who want to
control the weapons in the world and
those who want to have total freedom to
own as many weapons so you've got this
polarization a spiritual attitude or a
higher awareness attitude is about when
you have polarization find a third
position that serves both and if you
find a third position that third serves
both then you create what's called an
elevated paradox so what would be an
example of that in this context spend
billions of dollars on gun technology
and then open it up to brainstorming as
to what can cause a gun to not be usable
in the hands of a maniac so what would
that look like
right I'm confused well number one they
have on our phones they have face
recognition mm-hmm they also have
fingerprint recognition and they have
the ability to put fingerprint
recognition on a gun today so number one
if you're the registered owner of that
weapon just like if you're the
registered owner of that phone you would
be the only person that could turn that
phone on you would be the only person
that could turn that gun on secondly
every gun would need a SIM card which
could be where the GPS could be located
hmm there would be an ability to turn
off guns that got anywhere near schools
except for the guns that were owned by
police forces hmm now that's not going
to say that the millions of guns that
have already been produced are all going
to be rendered inoperative and so
there's going to have to be a rather
significant long game
but in the short game because many of
these people that have done these really
brutal and heinous crimes in the last
few years they've all bought their guns
they've had theirs record of them buying
their guns just a month or two before
and so what we're looking at here is
that no gun would be able to be used by
that person that didn't own it wasn't
registered to it it wouldn't be able to
be used in certain areas this would cost
billions and it would have to be run by
a government and of course that's going
to fly in the face of those people who
are still living back in 1870 that are
thinking that you know that having a few
rifles is going to be making you safe
and that you could raise a militia army
you know to take over the government
that is just not even
clearly possible yeah yeah well I see
that as technological aspects of gun
control that could work in concert with
you know more kind of elementary forms
of gun control like basically doing what
they do in places like Japan where you
have to literally you know jump through
hoops and take tests and get screened
you know be evaluated for your mental
health etc in order to purchase it in
the first place and then on top of that
to be able to have technological checks
and balances on the use of that once
it's purchased I think you know would be
amazing but I think more fundamentally
we don't have the political will to even
begin to implement any of that as long
as campaign finance stands as it
currently does but what if and I agree
with you 100% and not but and what if a
campaign was started first on social
media that no student would attend
school until something was seriously in
place I am strongly in favor of
basically a a walkout yeah there's been
some there's been some chatter about
that I think that there is a planned
walkout but it's only for like an hour
or something like that anyway this is a
walkout until it legs right exactly like
nobody goes to school the teachers or
the students until right and every
student in a public school brings I
think it's like five hundred dollars a
day some really significant number of
capital into the school system for every
day that the student attends to school
the school system gets that much money
for this for the student and so this
would not only be a demonstration
publicly but this would be a
demonstration financially that no
student will attend school and I'll tell
you the will right now is not with the
politicians they're still saying it's
too soon and well the same things that
they always say so forget that the will
is now with the students
the students believe that if they're the
ones that are on the front lines of this
disaster that they're the ones that need
to take passionate responses to the
solution and that is so I see this as a
many tiered event number one students
refused to go to school until some
significant first step is taken and that
first step has to be with a 2nd 3rd 4th
10th 20th step already planned out and
stated and the moment politicians miss a
step
students are out of school again and so
we hold their feet to the fire and we
say this is a just like with TSA they
said ok this is going to take us two or
three or four or five years to get into
place and I mean look at the first
installments of TSA were ridiculous I
mean they had a few desks moved around
and a couple of metal protectors and
crazy lines and the inconvenience that
that caused was severe so the immediate
situation is that you put fences on the
back side of the street in other words
not on the part of the street that's
right next to the school but you put the
fences across the street from every
school and you literally create a zone
in which nothing can get through that
would be step number one and what we're
talking about is yes we're talking about
a war zone malls the same way you can't
get into a mall unless you pass through
metal detectors would be an important
thing what else
airports they do it already schools they
do it but we have to get really serious
and we have to realize that just like
pain there's a physical level and that's
what's building fences and creating
technology and guns there's an emotional
level and that means like you were
saying in Japan that people have to go
through you know flaming hoops to try to
get a gun and then there's the
psychological level in which you know
there's a test and all of that and then
there's the existential level and the
existential level is that we really go
into the school system
because all of these people that are
doing these these heinous crimes are you
know like they're just absurdly
dissatisfied with whatever is in their
lives and they feel that being able to
express themselves violently is the only
thing they have left yeah that's the
more fundamental problem there's access
to guns of course there's the lack of
political will to you know basically
combat that but issues like all right
how are we screening people to get in
and out of schools and there's a recent
talk about putting drones above schools
like all of these things are are our
band-aids on the fundamental problem in
the same way you know taking a pill that
you know basically deals with the
symptoms of a disease but doesn't give
it a cause of it so to kind of dive into
that cause which i think is more your
sweet spot you know what is it that is
causing such an approach and resentment
and dissatisfaction and alienation with
so many people that leads to these kinds
of tragedies where the only path forward
for that individual is to go out in this
seeming blaze of glory and moments of
you know temporary infamy we educate the
brain in the head we don't educate the
brain in the heart and medical science
knows there's three main neurological
areas and we don't educate the brain in
the gut the brain and the gut is about
our connection our connection to
nutrition and our connection to the
relationships that are nurturing our
relationship in our brain in the heart
is about our relationships how we relate
how we give and how we receive the brain
in the head is about how we analyze all
we educate in schools is the brain in
the head we do a little bit about the
brain in the gut you know we talk about
these food categories but they're all
antiquated and so what we really need to
start
we need to overhaul the educational
system because the kids that are growing
up out of this educational system are
absolutely ignorant of the things that
you and I your lifestyle my lifestyle no
are essential the educational system
taught you how to be a lawyer being a
lawyer demonstrated how unhappy you were
hmm the educational system needs to
teach us how to be vegan how to be
nutritionally sound if you're not going
to be vegan at least gives some other
options here's a paleo diet right here's
a vegan diet here's a vegetarian diet
here's a regular diet and the idea is
that we actually teach kids how to be
happy how to be healthy and how to be a
whole person as well as how to do math
how to do science how to do the language
of their origin and some other languages
so they can speak to more people around
the world yeah it's almost as if you
know those traditional categories need
to be put secondary into fundamentally
connecting with the self understanding
you you as a human being exactly you
know what your heart is telling you and
and how to really channel whatever it is
inside of you to bring expression to
that and to do it in a way that leads to
fulfillment and self-esteem and all
these other qualities that will make you
a productive and essentially functional
happy human being and a teacher needs to
have appe that is in equilibrium is in
balance with the standard of living so a
teacher needs to be able to afford
everything that is taking place within
the standard of living of that decade
within the standard of living of that
country
because these are the people that are
with our most precious gift our children
from 8 o'clock in the morning until 3:00
or 4:00 in the afternoon every single
weekday and for them to be struggling in
their life means that they're not
putting as much into the life of our
child because they're having to find
ways of moonlighting and so we've got to
equalize the way in which our economics
and our economic structure works take
money invest it into security take money
invest it into education the things that
of course those who feel like they're
conservative conservative they're just
anal hmm they're not conserving anything
they're definitely not conserving our
children and so what we need to do is we
need to put money into those things our
teachers and the way in which we teach
them through the subjects that we give
in the class and then bring in people
like you and pay you you know a
significant amount to show kids how they
can become an elite athlete and be an
elite athlete in their 20s their 30s
their 40s their 50s and what that means
because you have so much information
behind the persona of what it's meant in
your life to continue to do what you do
at the age that you are mm-hmm yeah I
mean I as you as you kind of recount
that I'm thinking what would it take and
for something like that to happen you
know is this just a utopian pipe dream
and I think Andy there's the I don't
think so either but I think there are
plenty of parents out there who feel
that way and in a sort of sense of
despondency we're seeing this rise in
homeschooling because people are not
willing to drop their precious most
precious asset their child off at a
school
that's vibrating at a level that they
don't theme to be uplifting for for that
child and it's interesting to see how
these new models of education are
starting to pop up with little groups
here and there who are informally trying
to teach their kids in a new and
different way industrializing a nation
which was really taking place heavily at
the end of the 19th century and into the
20th century changed the way in which
schools were run the the major donors to
colleges were the large industrial
foundations the Ford Foundation Carnegie
Foundation the Rockefeller Foundation
and they were you know donating large
grants into the educational system at a
level of college you know the state
schools that were that were training
teachers and they made an error in
judgment they said because way back in
the centuries past we were educating you
know philosophers and thinkers and
writers and they said you know we don't
need philosophers anymore what we need
are the workers to be able to work in
the factories because now we're in an
industrial age we're in a scientific age
we're in all of these changing times and
so they made a mistake and they said
let's take out the classics so kids
didn't learn the etymology of language
let's take out the arts because we don't
need to create artists let's take out
music and they kept taking out the
things that are really wholesome the one
thing that they left in are all the
things that keep you capable of being
just an assembly line worker or
production worker and if you really
excelled then you would perhaps achieve
something greater than that this is a
long-term project but we're going to
have to say that in the next century
that we're going to start altering it
into a more positive direction just like
what was taking place over the last
century because that didn't happen
overnight they didn't remove all of
those
Essentials overnight and now we have to
start putting them back in so that kids
can really understand what education is
and we have to think about the child
that we're educating so that the child
can get excited and inspired about
what's happening in school right I mean
can you imagine a child coming home from
school saying oh my god it was so
mind-blowing we learned this today we
learned that today and yeah you know
excited about it and part of me thinks
like is that even possible is a child
wired to even have that kind of response
but I think it's possible but I think it
does require a pretty revolutionary
overhauling of the system so that kids
go to a place where they learn how to
feel good about themselves they learn
how to connect with what's important to
them and they're supported in pursuing a
learning process that has them
completely engaged that has them
learning how to team build and lead and
work cooperatively for the greater good
of the collective and like all of these
ideals that I think have just been
whitewashed away from our system all
together and I'd like to see you know
for you know for the sake of my own
children more of that in our system and
it's hard to watch and sit by and see
what's going on right now knowing that
there is a better way and and I think
when you see these shootings or you see
the level of disinfectant
people in their 20s and their 30s it's
heartbreaking because I know that so
much of that is so deeply connected with
how they were reared and raised in an
educational system that did not serve
them if you saw that young girl that was
speaking in front of the cameras yeah
with the very very very short hair one
of the things that she informed us in
her communication was that everybody
knew this child everybody knew this
young man who caused this horrible
disaster everybody kind of was on the
place of expecting this could happen
maybe not exactly in detail but they
weren't surprised that it turned out to
be him and I thought okay now that is
what we you and I and your wife and my
wife we have the skills to go into a
school system and there's people all
over the world that have the skills to
go into a school system and say okay now
we're going to start talking about how
we function as a group and how we are
able to see those amongst the group that
are dropping away from the capacity to
be joyful and inspired and there is
technology there is internal technology
that we can use to get children to do
just what you said come home from school
can you imagine what I learned today and
have that be a group project our son
went to a school that they were always
doing things as groups when they would
take a really big test they would do it
as a group because they said when you go
out into the world after school you have
to do everything as a group you put your
heads together and so they would talk
about what's the best answer to this
question on the test and they would come
to a conclusion amongst themselves you
would go through a school subject and
you wouldn't have six different really
important subjects in a in a school day
you would have to so that you could
focus like you you could focus on what
it is that you're trying to achieve and
so what it means is the system is broken
they say if you take an educator and a
and a doctor and a and whatever an
architect whoever it is and you take
them from 200 years ago and drop them in
today's world the only person that knows
their job is an educator
and that's because nothing has changed
in education and yet everything has
changed in the world and so what we have
to do is we have to go into schools and
have subjects about group consciousness
subjects about spotting unhappiness how
about spotting unhappiness how about not
just going okay that person is a jerk
and that person could be dangerous but
having the will and the wherewithal to
be able to go into the fact that okay
that person is really not feeling well
let's gather around them just like a
12-step program right mm-hmm
or select group therapy yes and have
group therapy start at the age of six
seven eight nine ten
where kids are very much schooled in
what its mean what it means to be
therapeutic in numbers and how you can
heal the the psyche of those that are
feeling left out because nobody that's
happy causes this kind of of course a
duty yeah of course not
and all the warning signs were there I
mean the kid got expelled I think and
you know there were several Turner's
there's a bizarre sort of lack of
attention to the suffering that this
person was obviously experiencing and
looking at it like that you know they
always say this person was evil let's
just take that evil title and label away
from it and say this person did an evil
thing because nobody spotted three years
ago or four years ago that this person
was going off at a tangent and that
tangent as we know gets worse and worse
and worse the further away from the
source that it travels and so over the
course of three or four years that
tangent is now a total clinical insanity
and I think that speaks to a larger
issue which is the disassociation that
we experience now as a result of living
in the modern world where we're just
we're fractured we're in Los Angeles
there's 20 million people here but we
don't really know our neighbors we're
not living the way we did for millennia
and arrives we're you intimately knew
what everyone was up to and if someone
started to go sideways there was a group
consensus or consciousness around that
to prevent that from getting out of
control
yeah but we don't operate we're not
we're not
wired to operate the way that we
currently live and so it's easy for
somebody like that even when there's an
awareness that that person is
experiencing some suffering and it's
potentially a liability or a risk
there's not really an infrastructure set
up in the traditional tribal sense to
attenuate that and we are wired but we
haven't activated the wiring we are
wired to feel each other and it's
through the gut brain it's through the
neurology in the gut that we can feel
each other so if we had a class in
kindergarten and first grade and second
grade and then all the way through
school how to feel each other's feelings
you know a class in empathy or
compassion whatever you wanted to call
it we would be developing these other
skills a class that works on the heart
brain there's a great book your your
listeners and viewers can can relate to
it's called M braining and it means
multiple brains and it's medical science
that's on the bleeding edge more than
the cutting edge and probably a bad
metaphor to use in today's conversation
because of what we're talking about but
the idea is that if you educate all of
the person that they will then choose
the right foods they will have harmony
through the heart in their relationships
and they can still do the analytics all
we're teaching now is to do the
analytics so they walk up to each other
they've got no connection so they
analyze each other and so the only way
those we don't know our neighbors and
we're 20 million people in a community
and we're seven-and-a-half billion
people on earth the reason we don't know
each other is because we're constantly
analyzing each other and the analysis is
two-dimensional like me not like me
meaning is that person like me or is
that person not like I am or not as I am
and right or wrong is that person writer
is that person wrong we need that dimmer
switch that is well they're not as right
as I am but they're not completely
so let me try to see what they're
thinking this is what we need and we
need to insert that into the system
humans aren't wired for that we want to
make we want to make everything clean
cut everything falls into a specific
category that I recognize so I can
organize all of these ideas that make
sense of the world or in since when
since when I don't know since when since
ever no just since science mmm five
about 500 years science 500 years ago
450 said we're gonna conquer Nate you
remember the quote right and obviously
we're being conquered by Nature because
we'll be wiped out but the fact is is
that we only became that two-dimensional
and that exacting and that needing to be
you know data when science took over
when industry took over when we were an
agricultural you know the rows didn't
have to be like that and what has
happened to I mean let's face it what's
happened in agriculture because you
plant all wheat all rice it's destroying
the habitat it was the people that just
sort of threw the veggies out and they
grew all different things in all
different places a little plot of this
and a little plot of that that was
natural and that allowed wildlife to
flourish now we've got bugs that we
don't want so we put out insecticides
and we do all these things that are
feeding that exactness of the brain but
we are not wired for exactness we are
striving for exactness were wired for
random creativity connected to logic so
that it doesn't run off the rails I mean
our head has to be here and our gut has
to be here but in between the two we
have to have some room to move I think a
tangential idea that's related to that
notion that that you know we as human
beings will conquer nature is the idea
that the intellect is capable of all
problem-solving and understanding yeah
that gets it
or which is cutting off the the
gut-brain
cutting off that natural inclination to
have empathy and to understand and to
feel not only is that not encouraged
it's actively discouraged all the
emphasis is of course on developing your
mental acuity while forsaking that got
intelligence in a very active way to say
don't worry about whatever your body is
telling you like you need to sit in that
chair and you need to learn this stuff
and after years and years of of that war
of attrition it just locks down and when
it percolates up the instinct or the
kind of natural reaction is to like not
pay attention to it or to try to
override it by virtue of the thinking
mind and what about a person that has no
skill in achieving that level of
intellect and therefore starts realizing
as they sit further and further and
further back in classroom until they go
out the back door that everything that
the world has to offer
has nothing to offer them and they start
to isolate emotionally then they start
to isolate psychologically and once a
person starts to isolate psychologically
they start to have you know repeating
thoughts and they start to have
attitudes and then they then they bring
that two-dimensional brain into play and
they start seeing everybody else
especially those that are doing well in
the world as the enemy and all of a
sudden you've got a potential mass
killer on the loose because if a child
doesn't have parentage that's going to
because the parent generation went
through the same thing and they're
saying to the child I have the same
problem it's not good for a you moz will
just leave all of a sudden this child is
in this world very complex world seeing
people succeed seeing his school
succeed and all of a sudden they feel
tremendous anger towards everything and
for we've got to pay teachers as much as
we pay doctors you know and we also have
to have as much desire to really make
children incredible as we do to really
make athletes incredible or technology
incredible or technology or anything
else and I think without some
fundamental perhaps revolutionary
changes in this system it's it's only
going to accelerate and the problem will
be exacerbated specifically or
especially given that with the advent of
rapidly developing technologies the
chubb that you know the job market is
going to shrink all these driving jobs
are going to go away like that there's
going to be people that build robots and
people that sort of attend to robots or
are told what to do by robots right now
it's like what else is left well there's
the artist there's what can you do as a
human being and you're unique you know
construction that you can provide the
world with that's a value that cannot be
done by an artificial intelligence and
what is that world going to look like
and I feel like we're kind of talking
about things we talked about last time
but I think you know unless we address
these problems with that shrinking job
market it's going to get worse I have a
solution that comes through yoga for a
part of this issue and that would be the
idea of breathing when it when a child
when a human being but when a child is
in school and they're finding something
very difficult their breathing pattern
will change so the difficulty that
they're experiencing psychologically or
mentally and emotionally has an effect
upon their breathing pattern so if we
would have every few
it's in school okay let's check our
breath let's let's do five minutes of
breath work we could bring everybody
back to a harmonious condition so
there's one particular issue and not
cost anything doesn't cost anything
another thing is as you and I both know
because of our dietary habit is that
sugar you know is the wrong thing to
have in a child's system anytime they're
needing to focus their brain because
sugar and the brain is like alcohol and
driving the two don't go together and so
educating a child about diet and then
getting in there and regulating the kind
of food that is available hmm
obviously we have to go back layers and
layers and layers and layers of
civilization in order to get this and
you say we need you know do we need a
revolution and actually we need some
evolution because a revolution is trying
to get something done very quickly and
an evolution realizes that it's not
going to get done quickly but we have to
do it over time and so what I would do
is I would say okay for people like you
and I and and others in the world that
have social media you know audiences etc
what can we achieve in six months and
what can we achieve in a year's time and
what can we achieve in two five ten
twenty thirty five fifty years and
really start creating metrics that we
can become attentive to so that we're
not just saying okay I lived and I had
an impact but no let's be like Cecil
Rhodes
he created De Beers right the diamond
company that owns the majority of the
diamond stocks in the world and controls
the prices of diamonds because the
diamonds are so plentiful that they
would be quite inexpensive if they
allowed all of them to go onto the
marketplace and Cecil Rhodes for which
they named the
unfortunately renamed rhodesia and then
they've now changed it back but Cecil
Rhodes created what was called the
Rhodes Scholars and the Rhodes Scholars
were if you showed a particular attitude
and and and aptitude to be able to have
a mindset you are given free college but
it was a free college through a certain
perspective to create world leadership
we need to do the same thing in the
reverse because they were creating the
world leaders the kind that we have
today that are not working out what we
need to do is realize that one man can
do that a few people through linking
through social media can do a lot and so
I think that based on this one disaster
in the Florida school that we could say
okay like 9/11 because there was a lot
of terrorist attacks before 9/11 but
9/11 changed things that we can say okay
this is the new 9/11 and there are going
to be TSA style checkpoints there's
going to be physical security there's
going to be emotional awareness there's
going to be psychological or mental
attention and then there is going to be
a metric that we can work with so that
we can get an existential sense and this
is what we're going to be able to
achieve in the first year and this is
what we're going to strive to achieve in
the second third fifth and really start
working like and it's people like you
and your wife and my wife and I and
others that if we start putting our our
efforts together
we can make a plan because everything
started with a plan you know airplanes
started with a plan of course and I
think there's some really simple things
that that you could begin to implement
that lack that the resistance we know we
can we can get that to important soda
machines in you know the schools we can
start looking at what school lunch looks
like and make incremental improvement
there I just had Bob Roth on the podcast
who runs david lynch's yeah lynch
foundation and he is having incredible
success with teaching meditation in
schools to underprivileged youths and
and was we were kind of discussed he was
sharing the the incredible impact that
this very simple thing is having on
these young people's lives and it's
simple things like that that I think can
begin to shift the emotional mental and
existential aspects of this you know
whether or not we need fences and and
you know metal detectors at schools and
drones like all of that frightens me it
doesn't need to you know it's like
that's not really the direction I want
to go I want to go the opposite
direction and start with the heart and
grow from there start with what we're
putting in our minds in our hearts in
our bodies and and again that's a
long-term thing but I find those
solutions to be immediately possible and
implementable today I am in 100%
agreement with you about the fences and
metal detectors and drones being
offensive but I look at it as being a
tiered approach I say that until we get
people re educated on a mass level which
i think is probably 15 to 20 years away
you know I think we have to get a
generation through the system first
there are some short-term needs just
like okay you're an extreme athlete and
you know that there are certain things
that you should do in the way in which
you run the way in which you place your
feet and there are other things that if
you do you will start getting injured
knees and injured hips but you had to
reprogram your body in order to know
these things one of the things they say
is that the invention of the sports you
also invented the sports and sports
injurious and it's because of these big
cushioned heels that everybody was
running incorrectly and you know running
on the balls of your feet is the way the
the body was meant to run
especially over longer distances and so
the re-education of the system is
important but what happens is that there
are sports injuries and those sports
injuries will require some kind of you
know invasive procedure to try to
correct and I think that we're looking
at the same thing here and that is that
the system is operating incorrectly and
it's going to have systemic injuries
which school shootings are an obvious
sign of systemic injuries and that we
need to have like a leg brace or a leg
cast or things like Ora a band this
tight temporary collab solution until we
fix the systemic problem yes yeah well
we're talking about social changes we're
talking about changes on the macro level
but let's shift gears and talk about
change within on the individual level
one of the things that you brought up in
a recent daily email was this idea of
tuning the self a tuning yourself into
the universe so can you explain a little
bit what you mean by that because I
think all real change starts with the
individual right we can't change the
system or society or culture or the
planet unless we first you know sort of
direct that mirror upon ourselves what
we have in our physical bodies is not
just the physical mechanisms that get us
through the day that have evolved over
millions of years such as the ability to
walk across the land to find food to
then locate a good place in a safe place
to sleep and to have shelter over our
head and then to find some social
interaction what we are doing is that we
are just external izing many of the
things that are on the inside of us
in doing that what we actually have on
the inside of us is we have a
sensitivity anthropologist understand
that longer ago than about ten thousand
years human beings and I think I might
have touched on this on a previous
podcast but human beings had another
actual sense called botanical sense and
the botanical sense was an innate an
inherent ability to EB in the presence
of a plant and know if it was
nutritional medicinal or pathological it
was a knowing just like you know that
the sky is blue you know that the leaf
is green because you're using your eyes
and you've been told ok that's what that
is so this sense was lost when we
stopped needing it and we stopped
needing it when we started cultivating
our food which was about ten thousand
years ago there's a lot of other senses
inside of us that we are not using and
one of those senses is that we can
attune ourselves to our environment you
know speaking about tuning to the
universe is a big subject but we can
attune ourselves to the environment we
can get to know that which is
immediately around us and this is
something that a child learns before
they learn to talk they learn to
associate themselves with their
environment and they're actually
watching skin tone facial expressions
and all and the and the light and the
eye the glint in the eye they're
watching in the shape of the of the
mouth they're watching all of these
things to know how to work things out
before they've learned to talk
reconstituting those skills is something
that deep meditation and breath
meditations give us and Transcendental
Meditation which you just mentioned a
moment ago is one of the ways in which
that can have
and the one of the one of the needs of
the brain is that it always wants to be
in control so it's always quite noisy
but if you can just insert a constant
tone and a constant few syllables which
is what the Transcendental Meditation
mantras are all about and you can do it
for 20 minutes in the morning in 20
minutes in the afternoon or evening
which is what the prescription for TM is
about what you do is you start to create
a correlation between you and the way in
which your brain works breath
meditations work the same way and so all
of a sudden this other sense besides the
five senses that we use and besides the
botanical sense begins to arise up which
is the sense that the pre verbal child
had and that was a sense that the Yogi's
back you know thousands of years called
vay us the Vai use and what you have is
you've got this area from the diaphragm
up to the top of the neck the bottom of
the chin and this is called the prana
value and it operates like a big sort of
like in these microphones or if these
were ribbon microphones it would be a
surface that was vibrating according to
the vibrations that were coming out of
our voice and so this area in our body
actually vibrates and when you get it
really sensitive you can be around other
people and you can feel their feelings
just like you can look at a person and
you can see them you can turn this sense
on like you could listen and hear them
you can turn this sense on and you can
feel them then there's another value the
two main values are what's called the
prana value which is surrounding the
heart brain and the apana value which is
from the diaphragm down to the pelvic
Bowl
it's called the the apana value and so
you can literally train these things
just like you train your ears and music
just like you train your eyes as an
artist to have what's called I hand
coordination you can train these things
we could
into school systems and we could train
the children to use this sense to be
able to feel another person's feelings
and if you felt that they were you know
having sincere problems then you could
get them help because it would be a
harmonizing thing tuning into the
universe I mean obviously those of us
that have been doing this for decades
not only can feel another person's
feelings but we can also feel the way in
which the cosmos is aligning we can feel
what's happening in a mercury retrograde
we can feel what is happening with the
redshift of the universe we can feel all
these things and so we can compensate
for it and there are ways in which you
can compensate for mercury in retrograde
which is a which is a disassembly of
communication right so you you know it's
like when you're running and if you're
running on a slanted surface that's
slanted to the side you can compensate
for that I know our daughter as you know
as a runner and she won a race in an
indoor track that was one of those Bank
heavily Bank tracks that some athletes
won't run in and so part of her team's
said that they wouldn't run it and it
was a and and she thought well why and
they said I don't like the bank track
she won the race jammed her hip because
of the bank track and realized that
that's why they had said they weren't
going to run it compensating for those
conditions is part of being tuned in hmm
compensating for a person's agony when
you're talking to them so that you don't
inflame their agony but you actually
calm it down like Bose headphones yeah
it's it's almost a way of talking about
expanding your capacity for empathy
mm-hmm and compassion right and I think
that gets to something else that you
talked about in another recent one of
your emails which is the power of the
the power of listening versus our
inclination to always be interpreting
I guess that's another way of saying
like being present and being in
awareness versus being in analysis if
you're listening to a person
psychologists have been studying this
but Yogi's and mystics and spiritualists
have been knowing it for you know
thousands and thousands of years but
when you're listening to someone are you
listening to them or are you thinking
about what you're gonna say in response
it's like this podcast is a perfect like
microcosm okay my whole thing is most
people say like how do you do the pie
how do you always know what to ask and
it's like because I'm I'm doing my very
best to be present and so at first I
prepare and I'm like okay these are the
things I kind of want yeah about but I
try to show up and then forget about all
that and just be as present as possible
but of course like I'm and I am and I'm
tuned in and I'm listening and if and if
you are listening yeah if you're truly
listening you should never be searching
for the next question because your
natural curiosity will lead you to the
natural next sort of evolution of the
conversation but I still can of course I
catch myself okay like we're kind of
winding up on this subject like what's
the next thing I'm going to talk well
that's the exchange of brain so you go
to the head brain and that's beautiful
well let me just say that is actually
one of the reasons why having these
sessions with you is so joyous because
you do what Yogi's call suniye ASUN ia
suniye means listening so deeply that
you're actually understanding rather
than interpreting what's being spoken I
try and I tell you I tell you you're
doing it better than anybody I've ever
been interviewed by and what happens
then is that because you understand
what's being spoken it naturally leads
to the next question and but you brought
it up listening you said and yes
the number one component in any
relationship whether it's an intimate
partnership a business partnership just
an acquaintance is do you actually hear
each other do you actually listen to
each other and below that below the
meaning and the definition of the words
that are being used there's a tone
that's always being used and the tones
the different tones have different
meanings when the voice rises at the end
of a word it means something different
than if a voice falls off at the end of
a word when a when you're speaking in
the tone or in the key of F it means
something different than your if you're
speaking in the tone in the key of G it
means something different if you're
speaking in the key of e so knowing the
tones and also the subtle tones within
the tones they actually have technology
now that there's this there's this item
out called a an amp coil and the amp
coil listens to your voice and it gives
you some feedback based on the tones and
undertones and overtones of what's
included in your voice because your
voice is a product of your entire body
being able to have that not in an
external device but being able to have
that same capacity within yourself
I personally listen to the words with
about 20% or 30% of my listening I'm
listening to the tones with another 30
40 50 percent of my listening because I
want to hear the tones will tell me how
the person feels the words will tell me
what a person thinks and so I'm very
much interested in not only how they
think but how they feel so and if I'm
not listening to them but I'm thinking
about what I'm gonna say in response and
I'm not giving a about what they
feel or what they think I'm just trying
to make myself be an important component
in the moment right and how is somebody
sitting
what are their eyes do what is there
what is there what is their energy right
I think that's as important those
nonverbal cues are far more illuminating
that what then what comes out of most
people's mouths and I think we're in an
epidemic of unlistenable don't listen
don't know how to listen don't
appreciate the value of listening most
conversations are a tennis match of
one-upmanship and and waiting for your
turn to then express your your opinion
on something without any openness or
willingness to bend or yield in any
regard based upon the information or the
energy that somebody else is directing
towards you and I think this is a super
important fundamental core illness
disease for lack of a better word that
is leading to a lot of these problems
that we're seeing there are external
manifestations of our inability to to be
able to be present for the experiences
that we're having with others that and
when opacity to be able to see that
other individual and say that guy's
going sideways that guy's going left I'm
telling you I can feel it I can see it I
can hear it let's do something about it
mmm you're absolutely correct because
the idea that we are working with each
other even if we're not connected to
each other but we're working with each
other we're working with the people in
Florida we're working with the people in
Russia what I don't mean that we're
actually engaged with them but
everything that happens on this planet
is affecting every single one of us and
so when we get to the place where we're
teaching what you were just talking
about the ability for you to know when a
person is going sideways and you teach
it a very soft level in first grade
teach it at a very soft level and second
and when you reach you know high school
it's a really clear skill set so that
everybody in the school is aware of
everybody else in the school
it's a transparency that is going to be
awkward at first but it's a transparency
that's going to be required because
otherwise kids get into isolation and in
isolation they become dangerous and you
know beyond that we end up in
ideological silos that you know
translate into television news programs
where six people in little boxes are all
shouting their dogmatic opinions on
everything and in this and it you know
it's it's supposed to be this rubric of
conversation but you know it's it's very
much not that and there's no there's no
effort or inclination to listen to
anyone else or to really engage in any
kind of productive dialogue that could
perhaps lead to the greater good of all
you said something ten moreso minutes
ago about vending machines you said you
know getting practical what we'll be
able to do over the next three years
because it's happening quite as you and
I both know it's happening quite rapidly
is we will be able to get people more
nutritionally aware and the first thing
that we'll need to I mean we're not
going to get people to go vegan you know
very rapidly but we can start getting
people aware of sugar so what if we were
to take one or two things on nutrition
on the nutritional level which is
physical one or two things on the
emotional level and one or two things on
the mental level and we'd say okay these
are the things that we would like to get
viral on a on a global basis and we
couldn't be too you know aggressive we'd
have to be reasonable but that we want
to get to have a really good
conversation around sugar and violence
right we want to have a really good
conversation about chemistry in food and
violence so that we can get some
document
just like we got documentation on
tobacco and cancer and we want we wanted
to take get some really good
documentation about the correlation
between listening and connecting and we
wanted to get a really good correlation
between what are some of the
fundamentals of empathy and what are
some of the empathic tricks that we can
teach an elementary school that we can
teach in middle school and we can teach
in high school and we just said okay an
empathic child is not causing harm to
others and how can we train this
starting at elementary school middle
school high school so that's the
emotional component that a child that is
not physically agitated is going to be
more attentive and the correlation
between chemistry and food we're not
attacking the pharmaceutical industry
yet and sugar and food yeah that's too
powerful that's a longer that's a longer
haul but we just got some simplistic
approaches yeah it's entirely doable I
mean if all you did was like we said get
rid of the vending machines maybe you
had daily check-ins with your classmates
there that are kind of premise taun some
standard you know psychological
methodology you had a 5 or 10 minute
meditation you had a garden either a
hanging garden or a garden where all the
kids would go out and be growing food
and I mean just simple things like that
I think could have a profound impact
down the line and I think you know we it
would it would go a long way towards
really starting to confront not only
these incidences of gun violence in
schools but the broader issue of just
malaise and dissatisfaction and
depression I mean depression is the
number one disability in the world and
and what's interesting about that is
the way that we've traditionally treated
it and the suffering that that causes
versus a conversation around the true
causes of what's leading to this so that
we can create better systems for people
to feel more fundamentally plugged into
their lives and more purposeful and and
more more fulfilled and what they do as
a way of eradicating the root cause of
what I think is leading to a lot of
these emotional disorders you brought up
depression there's an article just
recently in major publication that says
the people who are depressed use
language differently
that's immeasurable how does depression
affect language
how does depression affect word usage
how does a depression affect the tone of
voice
these are measurables when you have a
measurable you can have a standard when
you have a standard you can test against
that standard you talked about the
system in Japan where you have to jump
through all of these you know tests
before you can get a weapon imagine if
we were to be able to set up standards
if we were to be able to invest the kind
of dollars that science is going to have
medical science is going to have to use
regular science is going to have to use
and then all of a sudden what would
start happening is this these dollars
would start spilling over into
pharmacology when you have the majority
of violent children all with a history
of a particular pharmaceutical drug in
their system prescribed by psychiatrists
when you have when you look around at
the kind of reactions that fifteen year
old and 17-year old bodies and minds and
emotional bodies are having to the fact
that they've been on a particular
pharmaceutical ever since they were
seven years old or eight years old when
they working
to be you know hyperactive or whatever
then all of a sudden we're going to have
a larger percentage of the population
willing to listen to that the problem
that we have right now is that we have
just a very small percentage of the
population able to listen to these
things and a large amount of money
broadcasting the polarity and so what I
see is that over time we're gonna have
some things that we can address right
away but these larger issues that are
causing some of the really systemic
problems amongst children and causing
them to be extremely violent because you
didn't have this kind of extreme
violence except in Billy the Kid it was
a hundred and fifty years ago you know
very few kids were this violent but now
you've got a lot of kids that are this
violent and what we are going to have to
do is we're gonna have to switch out
over time that pendulum and that is
going to be very much a nutritional
thing physically very much an emotional
thing so that you know breathing and
emotions and all of the various ways in
which we can address that but I see us
succeeding I'm actually very very
hopeful mm-hmm
I believe that we've just passed the 911
for gun violence
you know plane violence we solved mm-hmm
plane violence we solved yes I hope so
yeah I saw every time I get on one eye
I'm pretty confident that we saw that
with the kind of security that I have to
pass through oh of course I mean the
security is insane I you know I I'm sort
of cynical about that a little bit me
too but just it's really you know sort
of for show as much as anything else if
there's a will there's a way if somebody
really wants to you know create harm in
that context I still think it's entirely
possible it just makes it a little bit
more difficult so perhaps they direct
that energy elsewhere but that's neither
here nor there but I think I agree with
everything that you said and we got to
wrap this up in a little bit here but I
I kind of want to focus on this
depression piece a little more yes you
know we've talked about kids in
education but for somebody who you know
depression is such a wide
epidemic it touches so many lives
directly and indirectly so somebody's
listening to this and they suffer or
they have suffered or they have periods
of time in which they experience this
kind of despondency and hopelessness
let's talk about some techniques for
thinking about that of redressing it to
sort of leave people with something that
they can actually practice in their own
life
all right I'd like to speak real
practically about this because that's
what really is important for I mean you
know we could speak philosophically and
existentially but that would leave
people with a huge gap between you know
he's talked really well but let's get
some practicality here one of the things
that is important in depression is just
understanding the word depress hmm when
you have anything that you're told you
have to depress that it means that you
have to put pressure on it so when a
person when a person is depressed it
means that the outside is pressing
harder than the inside and the feeling
is that they're being squished that they
have no space and at a certain point you
feel that you have no ability that's the
hopelessness that you just mentioned and
so we have to start really really really
small to get a wiggle space on the
inside of our being and that early
wiggle space is a mental space the
secondary wiggle space is an emotional
space and the tertiary wiggle space is a
physical space but we have to address
them in the inverse because there's no
way we can create mental space or
emotional space because that's not a
measurable right so you're not gonna
think your way out of exactly because
you I was gonna say because you thought
your way into it that which got you here
is not going to get you out right
so getting inside the space and this is
tai chi chi-gong kundalini yoga hatha
yoga running swimming climbing walking
all of the things in which you actually
can feel yourself stretching into your
body not just at the extreme and edges
of your body but in the inside of your
body so what is the one thing that you
can do on the very very very inside of
your body that you can stretch it
breathe deep and so you've got to do
things that cause you to breathe deep
which means that you've got to walk up a
hill or you've got to get on a treadmill
or you've got to go for a run or you've
got to go for a swim and or you've got
to get on a bicycle or a stationary bike
you have to do those things that are
gonna cause you to breathe deep you can
also just stand and begin to use
isometrics you know if you where you're
actually pressing your body against your
body which will cause your blood to
circulate more rapidly that's going to
require more oxygen that's going to
require you to breathe more deeply so
all of these things whether they're a
formal class in kundalini yoga or Qigong
or Taichi or you know and this is what
you and I are going to get involved in
in the actual courses that we're going
to create is how can we get people who
are out there in the world who don't
have access to all of these you know
gyms and this and that in all of these
classes that are in the major cities how
can they get out of depression because
as you said earlier so much of what we
do address is a symptom but nothing
addresses the cause depression is being
depressed it's being pressed into the
center of your being and then we have to
get ourselves out of the center so we
have to do those things which cause us
to breathe more deeply
and then once we start doing that all of
a sudden we start to get that wiggle
space now we start to feel you know our
emotional body starts to feel a little
bit of freedom oh wow I just had a good
thought our mental body starts to have a
little bit of freedom and I mean I have
had people say that you know just coming
to one yoga class or just coming to one
tai chi class changed the way they felt
the very next day and we have to get
that into momentum
yeah momentum is the thing and I think
that that I just want to appreciate for
somebody who is suffering from
depression just how difficult taking
that first action is because if to use
your analogy there's that pressure on
you the impulse or the inertia required
to you know put on a pair of shoes and
walk around the block could be
overwhelming because everything every
instinct every impulse is telling you to
lie in bed so that can be very difficult
and I think I think that the only way
through that is to find out find a way
to somehow like shut off the brain and
take action despite whatever your
emotional body is telling you to do
because you really do and I say this all
the time said a million times but like
mood follows action you're not going to
shift your Moot you're not going if you
wait around and say well I get that I'll
wait until I feel like doing it you're
never gonna do it you've got to take the
action despite whatever mood you're in
and that's how you're going to shift
that emotional state that is making you
so feel so trapped I really felt the
part of the audience that you spoke of
if you're so depressed that just getting
out of bed is a major operation a major
undertaking if that is the level of
depression that any of you are
experiencing just start with your hands
and stretch them just start with your
feet and stretch
because in your hands and in your feet
are a tremendous number of nerve endings
and when you stretch the flesh and the
tissue around nerve endings you get a
significant impulse and they've measured
it it's an electrical is called a piezo
electric pulse and that produces a
reaction inside of you and so if you
just start stretching your hands you
don't have to move your body you can
stay in bed just start stretching your
feet and your toes and then start
massaging your hands together one
massaging the other or each massaging
itself and then get down there and
massage your feet before you put your
socks on there are little ways in which
we can begin to improve the sensations
so that you have the ability to get out
of bed and to make a breakfast or to do
something that you haven't done for days
because we have all had deep moments of
depression and some of those of us that
are in really accelerated lifestyles
have had the greatest amount of
depression none of us made it to where
we are in this kind of an acceleration
that haven't experienced the other side
of it really really deeply and so this
would probably be a really good topic
for extreme fitness or elite fitness and
extreme awareness yeah I mean I think it
begins with acknowledging the the
reality of it and the power of it and
then followed by an appreciation and an
understanding that ultimately you have
to make some decisions for yourself that
you have to take personal responsibility
for that nobody else is going to solve
this for you and those decisions need to
be followed by actions and if the only
action you can take is stretching your
fingers then that's a great place to
start but ultimately the idea being that
you need to build on these things
and you need to create new neural
pathways and those are going to be
formed through the activities and
through the foods that you eat and
through the thought patterns that you
decide to engage with and it's a slow
process it's not like a quick fix or a
life hack but you know ultimately
there's a way through it and I think you
know just to kind of balance this out if
you're depressed it's okay
a lot of people are you know don't beat
yourself up for being depressed well I
always say embrace where you are I
always say if you're depressed you're
paying attention because there's a lot
to be depressed about one thing that I
want to also share is that anger is also
good because the one of the ways to get
out of being pressed in on right is to
get forceful and I don't mean angry with
another person because that's gonna have
repercussions I mean go out for a walk
where there are not a lot of other
people around and do some yelling
that'll get your blood going go to a
beach or a mountain or a forest or a
field and get angry or if nothing else
if you're still hugging in bed just
start beating the heck out of your
pillow because that in and of itself
stimulates the liver the liver
stimulates the diaphragm the diaphragm
stimulates the breath and all of a
sudden things start to work and it's
that you know that millay that that calm
that comes after the big storm of anger
that's our sauce mmm right yeah more to
be revealed to be continued to be
continued yeah thank you for doing this
today hey I am really inspired that this
is an idea that is on the table now it's
come off the horizon and it's on the
tank the Guru Corner they mean just the
Guru Corner idea and and the co-teach
yeah I think what a good way to end it
is to is to put it out to the people
that are listening if we
make this a regular thing we will make
this a regular thing perhaps if we could
make it a little more dynamic by making
it interactive and so if there are
subject matters or specific issues or
themes that you would like us to explore
in the the next or in future
installments of these sessions with guru
Singh
send me an email or send guru Singh an
email or share on Facebook or Twitter or
wherever you know what you would like to
us to us to talk about and all keep a
tally of that and perhaps we could pick
this up next time perfect with some of
those cool yeah all right anything else
you want to say just that what I said
earlier and that is that you have the
ability to listen more attentively and
more tuned in than anybody and I've been
interviewed by a lot of people than
anybody else in my world and that means
a lot because it allows me in my
communication back to you to be as
enthusiastic as you are in your
communication outreach thank you
and if you'd like to connect with guru
Singh the best way to do that well the
best way is to go to yoga West to go to
one of his class find yourself in Los
Angeles
Guddu Singh guru Singh Kham email at
info at guru Singh and your email would
work - yeah info at rich roll com - if
you want to hit us up with some
suggestions about that go alright until
next time my friend all right love you
love you - thanks
[Music]